En el último video realizamos una exploración
visual de la relación que existe
entre las sesiones a las que asisto
y el costo mensual de acuerdo a los distintos planes.
Así que aquí con esta recta en azul
visualizamos el plan de prueba,
mientras que con esta recta punteada en naranja, visualizamos el plan básico.
Y cumple, representa intuitivamente lo que
hemos entendido acerca de los dos planes,
para el plan de prueba, no necesitas pagar
nada en un principio
pero cada que tomas una sesión, que te mueves
uno a la derecha tienes que pagar 12 dólares.
Te mueves 12 hacia arriba, tomas otra sesión,
te mueves 12 hacia arriba, otra sesión más,
te mueves 12 hacia arriba.
Para el plan básico si hay que dar
un pago inicial de 20 dólares,
pero la recta es menos inclinada,
tienes que pagar menos por cada sesión,
en este plan al tomar una sesión solo tienes que
agregar 8 dólares al costo mensual,
tomas otra sesión,
solo tienes que agregar 8 dólares,
así que la recta naranja empieza más arriba
pero tiene una menor inclinación
y es por eso que las rectas
claramente se intersectan.
Y se intersectan,
las rectas se intersectan aquí.
Y la pregunta que ahora te hago es,
¿qué significa?
¿cuál es el significado
de este punto de intersección?
Bien, pensemos un momento sobre esto.
¿Cuál es el costo para cada plan
si solo asisto a una sesión?
Vemos aquí que para el plan de prueba
nos va a costar 12 dólares,
mientras que para el plan básico
si solo asisto a una sesión, nos va a costar 28 dólares.
Y no necesitas recurrir a las tablas que construimos,
lo puedes apreciar aquí visualmente,
para una sesión el plan de prueba
está abajo del plan básico, si vas a dos sesiones,
el plan de prueba
aún es más barato que el plan básico.
Aquí ves que estos dos puntos están más
cerca, la diferencia entre estos costos es menor,
para tres sesiones, aún el costo del
plan básico es mayor que el plan de prueba
y así vemos que los costos se van acercando
cada vez más hasta llegar a este punto de aquí.
Este punto es básicamente el número de sesiones
y aquí de acuerdo a la gráfica son 5 sesiones,
las cuales son el número de sesiones
donde el costo del plan básico
y el plan de prueba es el mismo
y esto lo vamos a verificar en un momento
y aparentemente el costo es de 60 dólares,
lo cual también estamos por verificar
y si vamos más allá de ese punto,
el costo del plan básico es menor
que el costo del plan de prueba.
Aquí vemos que si tomamos 6 sesiones,
el plan básico nos sale más barato
que el plan de prueba,
pero cómo le hacemos para calcular
¿cuál es de hecho este punto?
¿cuántas sesiones?
¿y cuál es el costo en dólares?
Lo acabamos de determinar a ojo
y esa es una gran ventaja de este apoyo gráfico,
pero que tal si quiero precisar el número de sesiones
y el costo en dólares,
quizás son 5.1 sesiones
y 62 dólares,
¿cómo obtenemos el valor preciso?
Bueno, una manera de hacer esto
es determinar el número de sesiones
para las cuales no importa el plan que elijas,
el costo es el mismo.
Sabemos que si elegimos el plan básico,
el costo será 20 más...
20 más 8...
20 más 8 por "s"...
20 más "8s"
y si elegimos el plan de prueba
el costo será 12 por "s", "12s".
Y queremos encontrar el valor de "s" donde
este valor es igual a este valor.
Es ese valor desconocido del número de sesiones
para las cuales el costo mensual es igual
sin importar el plan que tú elijas,
nos interesa entonces el valor de "s" donde
"12s" es igual a 20 más "8s".
Así es que hemos establecido una ecuación
con una incógnita que deberemos de poder resolver.
Veamos cómo lo vamos a hacer.
¿Cuál es la idea general cuando estamos
tratando de resolver una ecuación?
Y hay varias opciones para esto y es lo bonito
del álgebra, que tienes distintos caminos,
para mi lo primero que hay que hacer es despejar
las "s", hay que agrupar las "s" de un lado
y yo lo que voy a hacer es,
voy a despejar las "s" del lado derecho,
aquí tenemos "12s" positivo
y de aquí tenemos un 20  y eso facilita las cosas.
¿Cómo le hacemos entonces
para deshacernos de este "8s"?
La manera más fácil de lograr esto es restar
"8s" del lado izquierdo,
restamos entonces "8s" del lado izquierdo,
pero si hacemos eso entonces esta igualdad
ya no se va a sostener, teníamos una igualdad pero cuando restamos "8s" al lado izquierdo,
éste ya no es igual al lado derecho.
Entonces para mantener la igualad...
para mantener la ecuación,
restamos "8s" del lado derecho también.
¿Qué nos queda entonces?
Del lado izquierdo estos términos se cancelan
y nos queda únicamente 20...
nos queda únicamente 20...
déjame ponerlo con el mismo color...
nos queda 20.
¿Y del lado derecho qué nos queda?
Del lado derecho tenemos "12s" y estamos restándole
"8s", "12s" menos "8s" nos queda "4s"...
"4s".
Y ahora ya estamos cerca,
necesitamos dejar la "s" sola del lado derecho,
¿qué puedo hacer en esta ecuación
para tener solo "s" del lado derecho?
La manera más fácil de hacer esto es
dividir ambos lados entre 4,
así es que dividimos ambos lados entre 4,
no puedo hacerlo tansolo de un lado
y cuando divido ambos lados entre 4,
¿qué es lo que resulta para "s"?
Del lado derecho, "4s" dividido entre 4,
se simplifican los 4 y me queda tan solo "s"
y del lado izquierdo...
del lado izquierdo tenemos 20 entre 4...
20 entre 4 es igual a 5.
Lo habíamos estimado a ojo de la gráfica
pero ahora hemos verificado
que el costo para 5 sesiones
es igual para ambos planes.
Pero,
¿cuál es ese costo para cualquier plan?
En este caso podemos ir a cualquier plan
pues el costo es el mismo,
si tomamos entonces el plan de prueba...
si tomamos el plan de prueba
y queremos calcular el costo para 5 sesiones,
ese costo va a ser igual a 12 por 5,
así es que el costo va a ser igual a 12 por 5,
12 por 5 que es igual... que es igual a 60 dólares.
Ahora te pregunto, necesitamos probar también
¿Cuál es el costo para 5 sesiones en esta ecuación?
¿Cuál es el costo de 5 sesiones para el plan básico?
bien, no lo necesitamos.
Pues la razón por la cual obtuvimos 5 sesiones fue de considerar que este es el número de sesiones
para el cual el plan básico tiene exactamente
el mismo costo que el plan de prueba,
pero para que no te quede la duda,
te invito a que sustituyas el valor de 5 en esta ecuación.
Vas a obtener 20 más 8 por 5,
20 más 40 es igual a 60 dólares.
Así que para cualquier plan con 5 sesiones,
el costo total va a ser de 60 dólares
y entonces si agregas sesiones a partir de ahí,
si agregas más sesiones,
debido a que la recta del plan de prueba
es más inclinada, cada incremento de sesión
te va a costar más caro, aquí puedes ver
que el plan de prueba es cada vez más caro.
Entonces volviendo a la pregunta de,
¿cuál de estos planes es más conveniente para mí?
De repente encontramos una respuesta muy interesante,
si pretendo asistir en promedio menos de 5 sesiones,
menos de 5 sesiones al mes, entonces
lo más conveniente para mí es el plan de prueba.
Si pretendo asistir más de 5 sesiones al mes,
entonces el plan básico es más barato.
Si pretendo asistir exactamente
5 sesiones al mes,
entonces no importa cual es el plan que utilizo.